ومع ترد الوضع الامني في السودان اشار
شهود العيان الى ان المدنيين اضطروا في
عديد احياء العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم الى
تشكيل دوريات حراسه لتامين منازلهم
وممتلكاتهم في ظل استفحال ظاهره السطو
والنهب نتيجه التدهور الامني
تدخل الحرب في السودان اسبوعها الرابعه
لتحدث انعكاسات متعدده على المواطنين في
كثير من انحاء الخرطوم حيث تعرضت الكثير
من الاسواق والمحال التجاريه والمنازل
للسرقه جراء امثله الامن ما دفع المواطنين
الى البحث عن حلول لتامين احيائهم
وممتلكاتهم بانفسهم بيحصل
سرقه وناب
فهنا الحين ما شاء الله
ما قصروا يعني ارتكازات ما شاء الله على
مستوى عالي
فاغلبيه الناس البيونه من بره ويحاول على
سنهم يسرقوا الدكاكين فالناس ما شاء الله
تصدت لهم ما في دكان واحد في جريف غريب من
الحاره الاولى لحد الحاره الثانيه سرك
منطقه الجريف غرب احدى المناطق ذات
الكثافه السكانيه العاليه تجاورها محلات
تجاريه واسواق عديده تعرضت لمحاوله سرقه
ونهب من قبل اللصوص الذين استغلوا غياب
الشرطه والامن فتصدى لهم المواطلون الشرطه
ما موجوده صراحه والله الشرطه ما موجوده
لكن اولادنا قدروا يعني
الناس الكبار
من كل التفلات الامنيه
الوضع الامني المضطرب جعلهم يشكلون دوريات
حراسه ويجلسون لساعات طوال خشيه دخول
النصوص للمناطق السكنيه
الحراميه الكثير وكسروا الدكاكين لحد
الاولاد يدخلوا النوم كل يوم كاسرين دكان
الاولاد والله قاعدين في الشارع خلوا
بيوتهم والله
بكره الصباح قاعدين في الحته دي كان في
البدايه
لكن اولاد الحله
واجتمعنا كلنا وامنا دوريات
الحاجه في ظل الظروف الامنيه المعقده
والواقع المتازم بصوت البنادق والاشتباكات
العسكريه ارتفع صوت الاهالي بضروره رفض
الحرب املا بعوده الامن والحياه الى
طبيعتهما
لا للحق لا للحق
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات